GETTING THEIR SIDE OF THE
CONVERSATION.
>> ALL RIGHT.
FOX SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME JOINS US TONIGHT.
I DON'T WANT TO BE HISTORICAL OR
READ TOO MUCH INTO THIS BUT IT
DOES SEEM LIKE WE MOVED, AND YOU
HAVE MORE PERSPECTIVE THAN MY,
TO A PLACE WHERE THERE IS NO
POSSIBILITY OF COMPROMISE WHERE
ONE SIZE SEES THE OTHER AND IT
MUST BE DESTROYED.
>> I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THAT.
RECOGNIZED AS THE GENTLE LADY
FROM CALIFORNIA.
THERE MAY NOT BE THAT MANY
PEOPLE THAT THINK RIGHT NOW THAT
SHE'S GENTLE OR A LADY, BUT
THAT'S THE CUSTOM OF THE HOUSE.
IN THE SENATE, MEMBERS ARE EVER
DISCOURAGED FROM DIRECT
ADDRESSING DIRECTLY TO EACH
OTHER ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
THEY WILL OFTEN REFER TO OTHERS
SUCH AS, I DISAGREE FROM THE
DISTINGUISHED SENATOR FROM
WHEREVER.
THERE IS A REASON FOR THIS.
POLITICAL DEBATES CAN BECOME
HEATED, AND THEY CAN DEVOLVE
INTO THE BRUTAL AND BITTER
NAME-CALLING THAT WE HAVE SEEN
LATELY, WHEN THE MOST
EXTRAORDINARILY HARSH THINGS
VIOLENCE.
IN 1856, AS SENATOR FROM
THE SENATE FLOOR BY A SOUTHERN
THAT DIVIDED US SO DEEPLY AND
THAT OF COURSE WAS SLAVERY.
WE HEARD IN THAT ERA, AND IT'S
DANGEROUS.
IT'S AS DANGEROUS AS STEVE'S
AS WELL.
THAT'S WHY THESE TWO
INSTITUTIONS RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
KIND OF TALK AND BEHAVIOR HAS
CONSEQUENCES WHICH CAN BE QUITE
SEVERE.
>> Tucker: WOULDN'T IT BE
HELPFUL IF THE ADULTS ON THE
LEFT SHOWED UP AND SAID THAT?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE TRUMP,
BUT YOU CAN'T CALL PEOPLE NAZI
AS ANYMORE.
NO ONE IS SAYING ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
>> THE LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING.
THE PRESIDENT DEFINITELY
DESERVES HIS SHARE OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE HE'S
TOSSED ABOUT HIS SHARE OF THINGS
TOSSED ABOUT HIS SHARE OF THING
THINGS.
HE SAYS THE STRONGEST THINGS.
BUT THERE IS A CYCLE HERE.
THE PRESIDENT WILL SAY OR TWEET
SOMETHING THAT IS
CHARACTERISTICALLY NOT TERRIBLY
PRECISE AND VERY OFTEN
EXAGGERATED.
THE CRITICS WILL RESPOND TO IT
BY TAKING THE WORST POSSIBLE,
REACT TO IT ACCORDINGLY.
THEN THE SPIRAL BEGINS.
PRETTY SOON, YOU ARE HEARING HIM
ACCUSE THEM -- THE PRESIDENT
AND TIME-CONSUMING LEGAL PROCESS
TO KEEP ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSERS
FROM GETTING INTO THIS COUNTRY.
TRYING TO ILLUMINATE PEOPLE'S
DUE PROCESS.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, WHAT
HE DESCRIBED IT IS PRECISELY THE
WAY THAT MANY COUNTRIES DEAL
WITH ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSERS,
AND THE WAY SOME OF THEM ARE
DEALT WITH BY THIS COUNTRY NOW.
BUT THAT WAS LOST ON COUNTLESS
FRONT-PAGE NEWS STORY DESCRIBED
THAT AS AN ATTACK ON THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM.